معانا الان من الرباط الى الشرق الروداني
الخبير في الدراسات الجوسيه والامبيه
24 هذا الخطاب للعاهل المغربي في الذكرى
السابعه والاربعين للمسيره الخضراء تاكيد
من خلاله على الدفاع على مغربيات الصحراء
نسال الان عن دلاله هذا الخطاب بعض هذه
القمه العربيه التي عقدت في الجزائر وايضا
الدعوه دعوه العائله المغربيه للرئيس
الجزائريه عبد المجتبون لزياره المغرب
للحوار
هو كما جاء في الخطاب الملكي جاء في مرحله
حاسمه في ما يتعلق بمساله الوحده الترابيه
للمملكه المغربيه اعتقد بان خطاب العاهل
المغربي قدم اجوبه سياسيه لثلاث نقط مهمه
وقضايا استراتيجيه تتعلق بالامن القومي
للمملكه المغربيه قضيه الوحده الترابيه
حيث اقر يعني من خلال منطلقات علميه عمليه
بان مسيره التقرير المصير الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي نجحت من خلال تقويه قيم
الديمقراطيه التي اعطت بعد كبير لهذا
التطور ثم كذلك مساله التقرير المصير
الثقافي للمناطق الجنوبيه ثم جعل المناطق
الجنوبيه سي لتواصل من خلال خلق اليات ومن
خلق ضمانات وبنات عبر وطنيه نحو القاره
الافريقيه وكذلك نحو همم
قضيه مهمه التي ترتبط بالامن الطاقي
الدولي خاصه وان العاهل المغربي تكلم على
نقطه مهمه جدا تكلم ان هذا مشروع مشروع من
اجل السلام وبالتالي هناك همم رؤيه
استراتيجيه من اجل خلق الثقه داخل
المجتمعات الافريقيه وبين المجتمعات
الافريقيه وكذلك جاء الدول المهمه جدا
داخل هذه القاره ان تمكن ان هذا المشروع
يمكن ومن تعزيز قدراتها وتحويل الصراعات
والنزاعات التي تعيش وبالتالي اعتقد هذه
الاجوبه السياسيه مهمه ذات طابع استراتي
استراتيجي خاصه ان نتكلم
بشكل كبير على مشروع
جيوستراتيجيو اقتصادي كبير وهو الشروع في
المستقبل في بناء همم داخل الاطلسي الذي
يعتبر نقطه التقاء لمشروع من العقائد جيو
اقتصاديه على المستوى الدولي
استاذ شرقاوي كما تفضلت جرى الحديث ايضا
عن هذا الدعم الملكي لخط انبوب نيجيريا
المغرب وبعضه القاري ايضا على ان يكون
ايضا هذا تواصل بين افريقيا واوروبا وحديث
ربما هذا الخطاب كان له بعد براغماتيه
خصوصا في هذا التوقيت في ظل هذه الطلبات
الاقليميه والدوليه نتيجه هذه الحرب في
اوكرانيا هو ايضا خطاب ليس للداخل المغربي
فقط ولكن ايضا له الافارقه وايضا لاوروبا
الى اي مدى يمكن ان يسهم ذلك في حال حاله
الامور
اعتقد بان جلاله الملك محمد السادس من
خلال همم
التكلم والتطرق الى المساهمين والى احتمال
دخول مساهمين جد ودعوه الى الانفتاح على
المساهمين اولا هنا كانت اجابه على بعض
المحطات تشويش التي عرف هذا المشروع من
خلال بعض الاطراف التي تحاول خلق خلخله
هذه هذا المشروع وتحويله عن اطاره
الاستراتيجي والجيو اقتصادي والامن الطاقي
الحقيقي وبالتالي كان خطابا يعني يعني همم
حارس على تاكيد على نجاح هذا المشروع وعلى
تثبيته من خلال مجموعه من الاتفاقيات
الموقعه مع دول غرب افريقيا
ثم كذلك انه تكلم جلاله الملك عن الامن
التقى وجاء هذا في هذه السياق الحرب
العالميه الحرب الروسي
يعني الصراعات الجنسيه للطاقه التي تعيشها
همم يعيشها العالم وبالتالي اعتقد هناك
رساله مفادها الى همم دعوه جميع الشركاء
الاستراتيجيين للمملكه المغربيه للقاره
الافريقيه الى الدخول في هذا المشروع
الطموح والكبير لانه كما قال جلاله الملك
ليس مشروع الاجيال الحاضره بل هو للاجيال
القادمه ايضا وكذلك لمستقبل العلاقات
المغربيه الافريقيه والعلاقات الافريقيه
الاوروبيه وبالتالي نتم نتكلم عن مشروع
السلام حقيقي مشروع قادر ان يوحد
المجتمعات قادر ان يعطي كذلك همم عمليه
اجماع حول جيوش سياسيه الطاقه داخل ما بين
القاره الافريقيه وما بين الدول الاوروبيه
وبالتالي هنا تمكين هذه الشركه
الاستراتيجيه الافريقيه الاوروبيه من
محددات قوه جديده من خلال الانبوب الغاز
المغربي نيجيريا
الخبير في الدراسات الاجتماعيه